que cherchait les agents du fbi aille à
la résidence de danse chant pamart à
lago le matin du 8 août et pourquoi
maintenant et qui a donné le feu vert le
président
le président wade n'était pas au courant
dit la porte parole de la maison blanche
et silence radio au fbi m6 mais les
questions fusent de partout
pour ses partisans il n'y a aucun doute
c'est de la persécution politique contre
l'ex président
et ne devrait pas faire ça dit il c'est
une honte que c'est inapproprié celui-ci
l'on peur qu'ils soient candidats à la
présidence dit ce que l'on sait c'est
qu'en janvier dernier les archives
nationales avait récupéré 15 boîte de
dossiers à la résidence de dans notre
chambre en floride l'ancien président
les aurait rapporté de la maison blanche
hors la loi est très claire aux états
unis tout président doit remettre
l'ensemble de ces échanges courriel
lettres documents aux archives
nationales
même son ancien attaché presse affirme
qu'il était très négligents qu'il jetait
parfois les documents
et il ya deux mois quatre enquêteurs
dont le chef du contre espionnage du
ministère de la justice se serait rendu
à mahalla go rencontré les avocats de
dans notre chambre pour voir où se
trouvaient des dossiers il aurait même
réclamé qu'il soit placé dans une pièce
sécurisée selon les experts tout doit
être conservée aux archives nationales
car cela relève de la sécurité nationale
et le fbi ne lésine pas avec ces
questions là
c'est une journée étrangers dans notre
chambre comparant sa situation à celle
du watergate et tous les ténors
républicains dont le gouverneur de la
floride se porte à sa défense tous
parlent d' instrumentalisation de la
justice à des fins politiques
c'est intolérable écrit le leader
républicain à la chambre kevin macphee
affirmant qu'il y aura enquête contre le
ministre de la justice mary garden si
les républicains remportent le congrès
aux élections de mi-mandat gurnari des
foreurs nous sommes à 90 jours des
élections de mi mandat a dit il le fbi
avait fait une perquisition chez le
futur candidat pour 2024 je veux savoir
pourquoi manifestons les tournées faux
nom
personne n'est au-dessus de la loi a
rappelé mary gal lenze il ya un mois il
vient d'en faire la preuve dans notre
chambre pourrait se déclarer candidat
aux prochaines élections présidentielles
à tout moment et il espère que cette
perquisition va galvaniser ses troupes à
messi est un poète les galeristes
radio-canada washington